le placement en garde à vue ce jeune
athlète d'aval était attendu avec mon
associé nous n'avions reçu suite à un
article de l'est républicain qui est
annoncée déjà sa garde à vue il ya
quinze jours on m'y étais préparé
malheureusement est donc cette garde à
vue qui était attendue vient d'arriver
d'un autre côté c'est une bonne chose
johnattan va pouvoir s'exprimer parce
que les rumeurs persistent depuis
longtemps la famille de d'alexia soutien
johnattan je tiens à vous le dire je
vous rappelle aussi qu'il est présumé
innocent et que avec mon associé nous
allons tout faire pour que johnattan
sorte de ses 48 heures de garde à vue
libre
elle avait tout souci évident il nie
totalement les faits les a toujours nié
et il ya toujours la même position il
gardera cette position est ce que cette
garde à lifou revient avec de nouveaux
éléments
s'il ya de nouveaux éléments nous n'en
avons pas connaissance ça fait partie du
jeu d'une instruction criminelle
on ne donne pas forcément tous les
éléments aux avocats notamment
tant qu'il n'y a pas eu d'interpellation
qu'il ya peut-être de nouveaux éléments
en tout cas nous ne sommes pas en cours
pour lutter sur place il a assisté aux
perquisitions investigations il est sur
place bien sûr il assiste à tous c'est
la loi
quand une perquisition le gardé à vue
assiste à la perquisition et j'ai pu
m'entretenir une demi heure avec lui
conformément à ce que prévoit la loi
c'est un garçon très serein et même si
pour lui c'est très difficile c'est une
épreuve très lourde mais c'est quelqu'un
qui reste très serein et qui a toujours
la même question c'est savoir qui a tué
son épouse est ce qu'il est surpris de
ce qui lui arrive non il n'est pas
surpris personne n'est surpris 10
l'arrivée de johnatan on sait que la
justice n'a pas d'autre suspect en
l'état on associer mes spatafora nous
nous attendions à ce placement en garde
à vue depuis un certain temps quelques
éléments nouveaux sont survenus qui ont
justifié sa mise en garde à vue ce matin
je n'ai pas connaissance d'éléments
nouveaux qui est justifié son placement
en garde à vue je pense nous pensons
profondément que l'absence d'autres
suspects impliqués garde à vue on parle
de la dispute donc j'en avais
fait état lors de ses premières
auditions en tant que témoin ça peut
jouer dans cette prestation aujourd'hui
dans cette garden
tout ce que je veux dire c'est que
j'espère que ma femme disparaîtra pas
parce que les disputes on en a tout le
monde
c'est ridicule les disputes dont on
parle dans le coupe de johnatan ciel et
discutent ordinaire qu'on trouve dans
n'importe quel couple
on ne tue pas quelqu'un pour une dispute
vous dites qu'il est passé en garde à
vue parce qu'il n'y a aucune autre fils
ça veut dire qu'il ya aucun autre
suspect pour l'instant au niveau de l'
enquête c'est la seule les enquêteurs
non ça je lui réponds mon associé mais
aucune autre piste pour l'instant donc
d'une antenne d'aval subit finalement on
le fait que pas d'autre suspect pour le
moment oui mais qu'est ce qu'ils
feraient vue plus qu'un autre finalement
s'il n'y a rien dans ce dossier contre
lui ou contre dos et son mari exactement
parce que c'est le mariage exactement
et vous le savez on ne s'était déjà
exprimé sur ce point le mari fait partie
des principales personnes qui est
généralement sont soupçonnés dans ce
genre d'affaires malheureusement voilà